let's take a patreon question here have
you watched D'Elia on the show you know
I haven't and what are your thoughts on
him playing the ultimate creeper of
children I couldn't wait to hear your
thoughts you know um Chris D'Elia is
he's the embodiment of the dark arts and
people know it and he knows it if you
put your ear up to Chris D'Elia his hand
you can hear a bunch of [ __ ] you
know and there's a lot of rumors that go
around about him you know somebody said
when he was a baby that they had other
babies that had to live in his crib and
work for him and they would do all kind
of stuff and those babies wouldn't get
any milk and some of those babies they
would they just they get so dehydrated
that their eyes would be dry and
sometimes I started giving them water he
would crawl over by them in the crib and
just lick their eyes man that hurts me
knowing that that he could have done
that kind of stuff and there's other
stories out there too about him you know
somebody said that his hair actually is
armpit hair from a very tall man's
armpit and that Chris kind of bored the
guy to death one night by just yelling
oops
over and over again and the guy finally
couldn't take it anymore and his brain
and heart shattered at the same time and
then and Chris trimmed his arm the man's
you know that pit hair that [ __ ]
tertiary little that little because the
armpit dude it's almost like a vagina
there's no entrance and rumor is that
Chris then trim that hair there and
sewed it into his own head yeah so it's
just you know there's a lot of there's a
lot going on out there and you want to
be prepared
that's what I'm telling you thank you
guys for checking out this clip and if
you want to see another clip then you
can look at this clip or this clip
either one of these so did you pick one
or he's still just watching me do this
cuz it's alarming